The computer you see on my desk is the
one that I use when I'm making content,
editing video, and for a lot of other
things. But it's not the computer I do
most of my work on. Hell, I'm not even
recording on this right now. I'm
technically using a Windows PC in the
corner to film. But I've historically
done most of my dev work on this
MacBook. The same one that you guys see
is the one I use for my day-to-day
stuff. Well, it was, but that's changed
a bit. I need to explain why. But first,
I want to show you guys something. These
are the computers I do my actual work
on. Yeah, probably not what you thought.
and I need to justify the amount of
money I wasted. So, we're going to do
that with a quick break for today's
sponsor. You might have noticed that I
haven't been talking about Versel as
much recently. That's because I've been
using a different cloud for a lot of
what I'm building. It turns out that
serverless isn't the right solution for
a ton of different things. And since I
started building on Railway, I've had
way more fun trying things that I never
would have before. You might have seen
hints in other videos that I've been
building my own cloud. Believe it or
not, it's currently hosted entirely on
Railway. It's trivial to set up multiple
different real services with real
databases, real storage, and more. They
provide all the things you need in this
awesome canvas view for working on it.
But I got another fun thing to tell you.
I didn't set this up in the canvas
myself because Railway has a CLI, MCP,
and more in order to make your agents
capable of doing all of these things,
too. When you set up the CLI, there's an
option for agents that will go set up
their skills as well, which give your
agent everything it needs to actually
make changes on Railway, and it's been
super stable for me in all of my
testing. They also make it trivial to
spin up additional environments, whether
for things like pull requests or just
having a staging environment before you
actually deploy things out to your real
production instances. It's literally one
click in the UI. I needed staging for
Lake Bed, so I just did it now and it
was literally two clicks. That's
incredible. I will be honest though, I
was worried about pricing cuz spinning
up all these different environments
across all these different things is
kind of expensive with servers. But they
do things differently at Railway. They
only charge you for what you're actually
using. So, my service has spikes up to
as high as 12 vCPUs, but it usually
idles in the 0.1 to 0.2 range, which
means that's what I could build for
instead. So, you pay for what you use,
you spin up what you need, and your
agents can do it, too. What are you
waiting for? Check them out now at
soyv.link/railway. While I wait for all
of those machines to boot again, I want
to talk a bit about why I made this
change. It might seem a bit crazy as
somebody who's always been a bit of an
Apple fanboy, at least as long as I've
been making content for. Why do I make
the shift now? Why didn't I do it at the
start of the year when I first started
talking more about Linux, I started
playing with these other machines and
getting excited about things like Neri
and Cachios? Why now? I had a lot of
different reasons, but this one was the
biggest. When I use codecs on my Macs,
even on my remote Mac Mini, it just kind
of hammers my machine. There's layers to
this, and I'll talk about a lot of them
throughout, but it was getting to the
point of like unusable. And when you
combine this with this problem, which
we've all seen enough times now, the
person leaving their MacBook slightly
open because it's running agents on it,
I knew it was wrong, but it started to
feel even more wrong as of late. In
particular, because I've been running
agents to do more of the endto-end work,
not just making one small change, but
making the whole change, waiting for the
PR to be ready, get reviewed, and then
addressing the feedback. Those types of
longer running work became more and more
of what I was doing. and doing it on my
MacBook was driving me insane.
Especially when I have to like go do
other things because as much as I'm
clearly too online, I do also have to go
to a lot of events and meetings and
things in the city. And having my
MacBook stuck running work when I had to
run off and go do something was
obnoxious. This photo isn't me. This is
the one that always goes viral. My left
thumb doesn't work that well after the
surgery. My right hand could do that,
but this one wouldn't have a good time
with that. I found myself doing things
like this and not liking that at all. I
also found myself often in like bad
internet situations where my 5G was not
working great when I was in an Uber
trying to get some changes out and
having that all running on my computer
was obnoxious. So, I started to play
with cloud options and there are some
very compelling ones nowadays. I really
do believe that things like Devon's
cloud implementation as well as cursors
are genuinely usable for the majority of
day-to-day work and I like them a lot.
But there are catches. The biggest one,
and this is so stupid, is the
subsidization levels. Both Claude Code
and Codeex massively subsidize your
token utilization. Oh, my browser froze.
Great. I'm beachballing. Literally, as
I'm filming the video about Linux and
why I don't like using Mac OS anymore,
I'm [\h__\h] beachballing. Are you
kidding? Are you [\h__\h] kidding? I'm
going to blame Firefox, but it's still
annoying as hell. According to the most
recent research by semi analysis testing
out how far they could push the Claude
Pro Max and Max 20x planes as well as
the Chatbt equivalents, the $20 plan
gets you $400 a month of inference. The
$100 plan gets you 2,000 a month. And
the $200 plan gets you 8 grand on
Claude. And on Codeex, the $200 plan is
700 a month. $100 plan is 3500 a month.
And the 200 is 14,000 a month. So, if
you are going to use one of the cloud
IDE options like Devon or Cursor, as
much as I love both, if you're able to
use these subs, those don't feel like
good deals anymore. If you're an
enterprise and you can't use these
subscription plans anyways, you should
probably just go use those. But to the
handful of us that are building on
personal projects using these types of
workflows that want to be able to close
their laptop but also take advantage of
the insane like value you can get for
these plans. I think this video is going
to be really useful because I'm not
running these plans on my Mac almost
ever anymore. So what am I doing
instead? I've had all these machines
with tail scale and it's been pretty
damn awesome. I use them a lot over SSH
but I also use them a lot over T3 code.
I want to focus on the SSH side first
because I think it's really good. So,
here I have in CMU, which is the wrapper
for Ghosty that I really like cuz you
can have a sidebar and pin things and
notifications and whatnot. I have all of
my machines that I access regularly
pinned on the side here at the top. I
have my desk mini. This is my main Mac
Mini. I have a different one that's an
OpenClaw instance. I'm mostly letting my
team use that. I'm not using as much
right now. I have BB1, which is a
blackbox one. That's just my temporary
name for my new framework that I just
plugged back in. I have the Zbook. This
is my HP that I, as I mentioned before,
did most of my work on. Then I have a
Comfy UI rig. I forgot what this one is,
but yeah, I mostly use these two right
now. And there's a lot of little things
I did to my setup that have made it
really pleasant. The first is that when
I SSH in, it instantly opens up T-M. So
if I have anything going on in here,
like let's say I have BTOP open and I
disconnect, I SSH back in, it's still
open exactly where it was. This alone
has made this so much nicer. You also
can't see a lot of the numbers there cuz
I have such a small resolution when I'm
streaming. I got 32 threads on this
machine. I also have 32 threads on that
Zbook as I mentioned before. And right
now they're not doing much cuz I did
just take down them down and cancel all
the work they were doing. But man, these
machines do a lot of work for me. Like
absurd amounts. I'll talk more about the
work I did on them in the future, but
for now I want to focus on the workflow
and how I actually use these machines.
First and foremost, when I'm just doing
traditional like [\h__\h] around work,
exploring things, playing with the OS,
trying to get my network in the setup
the way I want it, I'll just hop in,
open up codecs in the terminal, and do
my stuff from here. And it's been pretty
dang solid. I'm not going to lie. I'm on
an alpha build because I noticed some
issues with the websocket server
connections on Linux. they have since
fixed them. So, I could get off the
alpha now. I'm just lazy. Whenever I'm
trying to work on the machine itself,
like I'm doing anything specific to this
computer, I tend to do it this way. Or
if I'm using features that are specific
to the harnesses, like I really want to
play around with ultra code and
workflows and cloud code, or I want to
use things like uh goals and sub agents
and actually see what they're doing.
Turns out codec CLI gives you almost no
visibility there anyways other than how
long the goal's been running for. But
for that type of stuff where I'm really
pushing the limits of the harnesses and
testing them, I have found using them in
the terminal to be tolerable. There are
some very big real catches here though
that have been driving me mad. One is
pictures. There are hacks that can make
this work, but I'm a person who does a
lot of screenshotting and pasting
screenshots to their agent. I get errors
when I do that over SSH because you
can't paste an image over SSH. Even
doing it in the normal terminal was
already a hack. So, there are catches to
put it lightly here. Also, when I'm not
on my home network, I have to connect to
a different address because I can't use
the local addresses. I told Codeex to
figure that all out and it was mostly
able. One thing I would highly recommend
if you're going to do a setup like this
is to pick the machine that is the
brains of the operation. For me, it's
this MacBook. This MacBook has access to
all the other computers. It has SSH IDs
already copied and keys so that it can
SSH without a password, which means that
my agent can as well. I also gave it a
skill that tells it all about the fleet,
all the different computers I have on
the network and what they are, where
they are, and how they're configured, as
well as a set of the default configs
that I like to use for this type of
stuff. So, I'm going to do a thing that
I want to do for a while. I noticed that
I have a much better like pure style
prompt on my Macs than I do on the PCs.
These ones, the Linux boxes in
particular, just have a pretty boring
bog standard prompt. So, I'm going to
fix that. I noticed that the Linux boxes
in my fleet don't have the same prompt
style as my Macs. The Macs use a minimal
pure setup with the colors matching the
system color. The Linux boxes do not.
Please fix it. And now it should notice
that it can use the fleet scale that I
built to find all the info about these
computers and then it can SSH into them,
see what their setups are, and then fix
them. I even have the computers MD file
that describes all of the machines that
is an optional attachment to agents MD
that my codecs on this computer can use
to go fix the things on the other
machines. While that's going on, I want
to talk a bit about the madness that
drove me here and then I'll show more of
how I actually use this day-to-day. I
hinted at this earlier with this
screenshot of one of my Mac minis at
100% CPU across all of its cores hitting
over 100° C in some of them. How the
hell did I manage to do that doing like
basic code work on web and mobile apps?
I'll admit that a meaningful portion of
this usage here is because I was working
on mobile, but the majority of it
wasn't. The majority of it was a certain
app called I don't even have it open
right now. Codeex. The codeex app is a
little bit brutal. It uses a lot of
resources. Not when it's idling, when
it's working. I'll demo this on my
actual machine. I'm on an M5 Max, which
my face is covering the part that
matters here. It's got 18 cores, 18
threads, so to speak. And this can do a
lot. And right now, it's not doing too
much. Codeex is open. It is taking some
of the CPU. Watch what happens when I
ask it to do anything, especially if it
involves computer use. Let's come up
with something good. Said, "Go through
the recent replies on my Twitter using
computer use to find any replies that
could be good video topics." Now we're
going and let's hop back over to my
terminal and take a look at the
utilization on my machine and also
activity monitor over to CPU and you'll
see we went from like nothing using more
than 10% to half of my cores being in
the 20s. Now it is navigating through my
Twitter and doing things now in
mentions. And while this is all going
on, you can see that my CPU is under
quite a bit of load. And this is one
thread of browser use. Now imagine I'm
doing two or three things at the same
time. You can clearly see how I would
quickly end up using the entirety of my
CPU, even on a maxed out M5 computer
that now costs $10,000. That's like
three things you can work on at a time.
And as these tasks get bigger and longer
and slower, this can get really bad. One
of the biggest issues I have had using
codecs on a Mac and using Macs for lots
of agents in general is this CIS policyd
thing. This is a very much Mac thing
where Apple tries really hard to keep
their computer super secure. They went
hard on the marketing of like the
computer with no viruses back in the day
and they have tried their hardest to
maintain that since. So whenever new
processes spin up, they have a system
policy manager that tracks those
processes to make sure they're not doing
anything sketchy. And this works fine if
you're spinning up a normal amount of
processes, but something like Codeex
spins up a shitload. And there's
additional problems here like when codec
spins up sub aents because every sub
aent also needs to have the ability to
call computer use which is an MCP which
means the MCP has to spin up on the
server side with one unique process for
every single thread as well as a
connection client for it too which means
every sub agent gets like 30 plus
processes for all the things it can do
and all the MCPS it has built in which
means it's very very easy to get crazy
numbers just from CIS policyd monitoring
the processes on your computer. If you
haven't seen this, you haven't asked
Codeex to do sub agents. And as soon as
you do, you will see horrible numbers on
your Mac. You'll actually probably hear
it first when your fans start spinning
up. This was driving me [\h__\h] insane.
It made me hesitant to use codecs. It
made me hesitant to use sub agents. It
made me hesitant to like do real work on
my computer. Even now with it idling,
it's using a shitload of CPU. And if I
command Q item and wait a sec, a lot of
those numbers are about to drop down.
Yeah, already going down a bunch.
They're working on it. I expect it to
get better. It's already improved a
bunch since the peak of how bad it was,
but I I'm annoyed and I want a lot of
the benefits of codeex without having to
deal with that. And that's why I started
exploring Linux as an option. There was
one other issue I was having with Macs,
though. And it's not just like
navigating. As you see, I'm still using
a Mac for doing the work or triggering
the work at least. My other issue is
this post from Nolvox Populi back in
March of this year that I've thought
about almost every single day since.
This is a benchmark that measures how
quickly small files can be created and
deleted and recalled for doing things
like cleaning up your Git history,
cloning a Git project, PNPM installing a
bunch of things from cache. A lot of the
types of tasks that we used to do a
decent bit, but we now do way more when
we're spinning up things like work trees
for sub aents and other things that are
running on our machines, being able to
clone a bunch of small files went from a
thing you do occasionally to a thing I
personally do dozens of times a day and
it's annoying. So, let's start by
running the get clean command in this
project that is designed to be like a
bunch of big projects to replicate these
performance issues. Here it is running
on my Mac, my M5 Max MacBook with insane
file speeds. It's IO is unbelievably
powerful versus random Linux box on my
network.
You can probably already see the
difference. It just did that in 2.5
seconds real time. My Mac is still
going.
This will be a bit
Let's just wait for a sec.
Okay, that took 20 seconds. 35 total for
real time. So, we go from 2 seconds on a
framework desktop to 35 seconds on a
topofthe-line maxed out MacBook Pro. And
now we can do the install test. This
one's even more fun. Let's do this one.
Yeah, the Linux is a lot faster. You can
very clearly see this is installing a
bunch of packages in a bunch of repos, a
bunch of sub projects effectively. And
it just did it on my Linux box in 7.5
seconds. Sorry, 7.3 total. And the Mac
is still going.
35 seconds again on the Mac, but the
ext4 system is still almost 30 times
faster than my Mac for day-to-day PNPM
install type tasks. Do you understand
how insane that is? The SSD on this
computer is two to three times faster,
but the framework in reality is more
than 10 times faster for just cloning
work trees and doing PNPM installs and
these types of day-to-day things. It's
insane how much better it feels and how
much less hesitant I am to like spin up
a work tree now. And that's what this
benchmark highlights. On most like Linux
boxes using pretty much any file system,
you'll get performance where the these
tasks take under 10 seconds. But on any
MacBook running APFS is going to take 30
plus. It's pretty bad. It's pretty damn
bad. APFS is rough for the types of work
that we do. There were a few things I
was hesitant about before I made this
move. One was the SSH stuff that I
talked about earlier. It's rough, but
I'll show you how I solved it. Just like
not being able to paste images is the
worst. I promise I have a good solution,
though. That was one of the things. The
others were things that were kind of
macky. Like I really enjoyed having 128
gigs of RAM that was shared between CPU
and GPU cuz I could use that to run
local models and I could use that to do
my day-to-day work. On PCs, you usually
have VRAM on your GPU and normal RAM on
your CPU. So you don't get that level of
like being able to run a giant model on
the machine. I don't [\h__\h] care
anymore. I'm going to be real. I'm using
the cloud models. If I want to use one
of the cool openweight models, they're
cheap enough from external hosting. I
just use that. I'm not that into running
models on my local network. I just don't
care. So, that change was pretty big. It
meant that my willingness to consider
non-Apple computers for this went up a
bunch. But, I also really started to
like computer use, and I knew I would
miss it a lot cuz I know that the Codeex
team has worked really hard on the Mac
computer use implementation, doing crazy
things like running when your computer's
display is turned off or having access
to applications that you don't even have
open on the screen at the time. Computer
use has gotten really damn good in Mac
OS on codecs more than I ever thought it
would. As somebody who is very skeptical
of this type of thing before, you can
use computer use on Linux. It's nowhere
near as stable, but I also don't find
myself needing it as much. What I have
found myself doing more is going to
computers like my Mac minis, just giving
them one specific computer use task and
then using these Linux boxes for all of
my actual work. And that's been going
really well, especially when you give
these computers access to each other
where I set up my Linux boxes to be able
to SSH into my Mac Mini and spin up
things with codecs that can use computer
use on that computer. That works way
better than I expected it to. But I do
have one more trick I want to show a
bit. This is the one that's going to
make the video kind of long. The magic
trick is this guy. This is the Comet Pro
by Galinaut. I love this device. If
you're not familiar with network KVMs,
they're really goddamn cool. I've tried
almost all of them. The Jet KVM started
this new trend and I like it quite a
bit, but the performance on the Jet KVM
wasn't great. It felt kind of laggy when
I used it. I did not have that problem
with the GLET equivalent. This guy
doesn't look like much. It effectively
is like a Raspberry Pi type thing
inside, but the ports are where it gets
interesting. Uh phase, feel free to
zoom. We got an HDMI in and out. Out
barely matters. The in is the key. We
have two USBC ports. One is a 5volt 2
amp. That's for power. And the other one
has a keyboard and a mouse icon. You
might be thinking, wait, are you going
to control this by plugging in a
keyboard mouse? No. It's also got
Ethernet, which is not super important.
It's just one of the ways you can
connect it. What this guy is is a
monitor, keyboard, and mouse for a
computer like this guy. If I want to be
able to control this computer and have
proper full control of this computer
when I'm not at home, I need the ability
to see what it's showing, not just SSH
into it, I need to be able to reboot it
or maybe flash a different OS on it and
really control it. And that's what this
does. I plug the HDMI and USBC from this
mini computer into this. And now I can
fully control it like I'm team viewering
regardless of what software is on the
box. And godamn can you do cool stuff
with this? Much more so than I even
thought you would be able to. One last
thing before I go set this up. I am not
sponsored or affiliated with GLET in any
way, which is crazy considering how much
of their hardware I have. I love these
guys so much. Uh GLET, if you guys are
watching this, I want to work with
y'all. Respond to my emails. You can
find my email in my YouTube channel. I
will help you sell so many devices.
Everything you've ever made has been one
of my favorite versions of that product
line. Let me help you guys. Seriously,
your shit's so good. Be right back. It's
booted. It's on my network. Flashbang
warning. We're now in. I'd like to
remind you this is not some software
running on the computer. This is an
external device that is able to fully
control the computer, which means you
can do crazy things like reboot it.
I have full control of this machine. Do
you understand how useful this is? I can
control the bootloader. One of the
coolest things these offer now is the
ability to connect storage too. So I can
put an ISO on here, mount it, and flash
a different OS on the machine. How much
of my audience do I think doesn't know
what a network KVM is? Let's do this.
Did you know about network KVMs before
this? About half of y'all, the most
locked in people hanging out here, did
know about this, but a lot of you guys
didn't, and they're really [\h__\h] cool.
This machine already has stuff
configured on it, which means I can't do
some of the things I wanted to show here
specifically because I was letting
Julius use this a few days ago and I
know there's stuff in here that he wants
to get off it. So, I can't nuke the
machine as much as I want to. Believe
me, I want to. As I mentioned before,
computer use is something I really like.
This is not a real practical demo, but
this shows you the capabilities here in
a way that I think is really cool. I
just told Codeex to use computer use in
Helium to configure my Ubuntu machine
over the network KVM. It's on this URL.
It's this tab. I want the wallpaper to
be solid black instead of a picture. And
now we can watch it as it works. And now
we see the magic little cursor there
coming in from codeex. And it is
learning how to use the computer. This
might be interesting because Ubuntu is
not the uh the best UX for a desktop OS.
I mostly use Ubuntu server which has
been serving me very well. I was just
lazy installed standard Ubuntu on here.
But here just opened the terminal up. It
is now going to send commands to the
terminal. So it doesn't know it can SSH
in. And so I was going to do this
instead, but like I think that's cool as
[\h__\h] What I used this for a few days
ago that that melted me, and I've been
waiting to talk about this, and I'll
probably talk about more in future
videos. Wink wink. I used this to debug
a broken Linux install I had on a
different computer. I had a machine on
my network with two drives in it. One
was 1 TB, one was 4 TB. I added the 4 TB
later. I wanted the 1 TB drive from it,
funny enough, to put into this
particular computer. Also, it just
successfully did the change. Pretty damn
cool. So I asked Codeex on that machine
to copy over the partitions so that I
could rip out the drive and boot it. It
copied over the partitions, but it
wasn't bootable. That computer also had
one of these KVMs on it though. So I
opened up the KVM. I opened up Codeex on
my laptop and said, "Hey, this
computer's not booting. The partitions
should have the data we need though. Can
you recover its boot?" And in the Grub
boot loader, it was able to force a
boot, get into the system, and then
repair the partitions without me
touching the computer. I just set the
command, saw it work. It's like, okay,
this might figure it out. Left for 20
minutes, came back, and my machine was
working again. Unfucking believable.
It's so cool how far these things have
gotten. And it succeeded. It completed
its task. It's confirming here, giving
me its feedback at the end. Do you know
how cool it is giving AI access to
literally any computer in the world by
plugging a little box into the HDMI and
USB ports? It's magical. And if you're
wondering what happens if the computer
gets turned off accidentally or
something or you need to do a hard
reboot, GL Inet's the only provider that
sells a good solution for this for all
computers. Pardon my language. It's
called the Fingerbot. This is one of my
favorite things in ever put out. This is
a robotic finger. It's battery powered
and connects wirelessly to the GLKVM. It
also has like a 3M strip when you get
it. So you 3M this right next to your
power button and then you can tell in
the GLET software tell it to click and
press and how long to press for and it
can hard reboot your computer remotely.
It's so useful. I've been able to
install different OSS on machines from
the other side of the country without
having to ask anybody to go press a
button for me. It's really damn cool.
Would I use this to control this
computer remotely? Like would I browse
the web through this? No. That would be
awful. It's not good. It's good enough
to do work and like get things done, but
I see this more as an emergency
interface and a way to give agents the
ability to control the full computer
remotely. And for those two things, it
has been unbelievably helpful. I now
have this type of KVM on most of my
remote machines, especially the ones
that actually have a guey. So, all my
Mac minis have this. Two of my Linux
boxes do, including this one I just set
up. Now, it's really nice when you do
need to do things in the guey or format
the machine, that type of thing. It's
time to show you guys how I actually do
work using this setup. npx t3 at nightly
serve. I do have these host commands to
make it work better with tail scale. Now
that is served. And what this means is I
can now connect to T3 code over my tail
scale address or my local network and
control everything going on in that
machine through an actual guey that
works. And it is so goddamn good. You
can even use the terminal through T3
code as well. And here we can see, oh,
my fancy terminal changes I queued up at
the start persisted. I can get pull. So,
we're on latest. Exit. We're back in T3
code. So convenient. I want to actually
use this a bit though. So, let's cue
something up. What's the status on the
orchestrator
changes that Julius is working on? It
might still be in a branch and PR and
not yet merged. And I'm going to throw
this on a work tree just because they're
basically free on Linux. And now we're
in a work tree working on some real work
remotely. But most importantly for me, I
have screenshots again. So I can just
grab the screenshot, paste it, say it's
this one. And now I'm sending images
again on a machine that I'm accessing
remotely, which by the way, I can switch
over to doing this on like 5G or a
different network. And since I'm tail
scaled in, we're all good. It's so nice.
I have been using this a ton for my real
work across all the different machines.
And just to emphasize how much less I'm
doing on my machine lately, I do have to
wipe my T3 code history somewhat
regularly when I'm testing stuff, but
like this is all I have in it and those
are 23 days ago. I'm not using T3 code
on this machine for my work. I'm
accessing it remotely. You'll see here I
have a lot more work that I've been
doing over on this brand new machine and
then I have a separate one where I have
even more. All it took to get Theo Linux
pill was a fast file system and a
fingerbot. You're not wrong. I'm going
to set up the remote stuff. We do have
T3 connect coming which will allow you
to not use tail scale. I haven't even
tried it yet. I don't know if we're
going to charge for it. I have no idea
how we're going to figure that all out.
Julius has been deep on that for a bit
now. We're trying to get some changes on
the Cloudflare side so we can do it
right. But for now, I'm just connecting
over with Tailscale. And this goes both
ways, too. Once you install the desktop
app, you can check this box and expose
your T3 code over HTTPS over Tailscale.
But I want to connect to this other
machine. So, I'm over to my terminal. It
gave me this URL over here. I'm going to
grab this, but I'm going to change it
slightly because it didn't realize it's
tail scale on that side. So, I'm going
to fix that by creating link. I want to
go the other way. Remote environment.
Add paste. This is the pair code. I want
this version of the URL. So, I'm going
to do that instead. Now, I have that as
a remote environment in the T3 code
desktop app. Do you know how much more
cool this is going to be when the mobile
app's supported too? And now it shows
when I go to work in a project which
machine it's on as well as which
directory it's in because I have
multiple clones of the same repos
because that's how I would solve the
work tree problem when work trees
weren't good. Now they're better cuz I'm
on Linux. Still not great but much
better overall. And I can see all the
different machines their names and the
directory the code is in. And I can even
add projects on different machines. If I
have a folder on this other box, I can
find it and add directly from there or
even give it a git URL to clone on that
remote machine. So if I want to grab, I
don't know, round the codebase for the
ping.gg site and have it on here. Get
clone paste. Enter. It wants to go
somewhere. So we'll do code uh work
round create and clone source control
operation could not be completed. We
have better error here. Oh, I might not
have a GitHub CLI set up here. Yeah, I'm
not. Cool. So, that couldn't access it
because I don't have GitHub set up on
this. You know what? I'm gonna do this
the way I normally do it. I just did
this config here with the change to the
prompts. I want the O working. So, I'm
just going to tell it uh GitHub O for
Git and GH CLI is not working on BB1.
Fix it. I could go sign in manually, but
now that this MacBook has access to all
the other computers over SSH, it can go
do that for me. But I know I have this
on ZBook. So let's do it there.
Settings, connections, add environment,
paste, add. Cool. And if we go back to
where I was, add project zbook GitHub
repo. I can find it this way.
ping.gground.
There we go. And I want this in code
work. I already have one there. I'll
call it round two. Create. And now I
have cloned and will be able to work in
this project entirely remotely without
having direct access to the machine. And
this will work over the cloud. This will
work over my local network. This will
work even if I close my laptop, which is
the magic of it all. What's the current
state of this project? God, this is so
cool. Being able to control these other
machines on my network without having to
be directly connected or accessing them
through something like this where it
feels effectively native. And I have the
terminal here. I have all of that. And
if I ever need to access it on this
machine, I can tell the agent or even
tell the orchestrator at this top level
on my laptop, hey, I want to access this
port on this machine to check out this
web UI or check out this other thing.
And it works. This has fundamentally
changed the way I work and the things I
do with agents. Now I can run these jobs
for so much longer and not worry about
having to like close my laptop or
melting the CPU and memory on it. I'm
running much longer jobs. I'm not just
telling the agent, go make this change.
I'm telling it, investigate the codebase
to figure out the right way to do this
thing. Make the changes. Put up the PR.
Wait for the bots to review it. Respond
to the review comments. Maybe go ask
Claude for its opinion, too. And don't
bother me until you're done. You also do
stupid things like this. I'm just going
to whisper flow cuz I'm being lazy. I
want to modernize this project. Its tech
is very far behind, and it hasn't been
wellmaintained for a while. I want you
to audit the project. Use sub agents to
break up the work and figure out all of
the things that are worth modernizing or
deprecating and then write an HTML plan
when you are done. Respond with the link
to that HTML plan and away it goes. I
don't have to worry about it. I don't
have to think about it. I can come back
later and have a little URL I can click
that breaks down this project and what
it thinks should be done to it. It's so
good. It's so good. The way I work with
agents and the amount of work I do with
agents has fundamentally changed as a
result of setting up these boxes and
connecting to them through something
like T3 Code. It's just night and day
difference. It feels so much better to
do work this way. I highly recommend you
try setting this up yourself. You're
wondering about the HTML hosting. I made
a dumb microser for it. I recommend you
do the same. I might put mine out, but
it's easy enough to build. Just go build
it yourself. You might think you need a
really big, beefy, powerful computer to
benefit from this type of setup. I can
tell you for a fact, having initially
done this on a much, much less powerful
computer. It doesn't really matter too
much. Linux is just a much better OS
than Mac OS for this type of parallel
work. And as such, most Linux distros on
most computers will be really nice to
offload work to, especially if you have
a lot of threads. Like here, that box
that I just spun up all those sub aents
on that I'm also accessing T3 code
through is using like nothing for
resources. It's got 32 cores or 32
threads and I'm using like 8 to at worst
like 20% but usually not even close.
It's using jack [\h__\h] And that project
it's auditing isn't using PNPM or bun.
It's using OG npm. So it's it's a hog
and it's fine. This computer isn't
breaking a sweat at all about this. And
my most importantly though, my laptop
isn't doing [\h__\h] I still have codeex
open, which hurts. But if I close that,
it's not using jack [\h__\h] for resources
in comparison. It's so nice. It's so
nice. But if you are looking for a
computer to run this on, I'm going to
ruin things for myself again here. The
GMT K8 Plus is the computer I am using,
the one that I showed here that I just
set up with the KVM. more than enough
computer for this type of stuff. Without
RAM or an SSD, it's only 400 bucks with
with 32 gigs of RAM and a 1 TB SSD is
currently on sale for 740. And that $300
jump for 32 gigs of RAM and a terabyte
drive is actually a pretty damn good
deal because buying those separately
would cost even more. So, if you're
looking for a rig, this one's probably
going to sell out fast. Worth
considering. I don't get any affiliate
deals when you buy from GMK Tech. I'm
not even going to link it. Just go find
it. It's a good deal. It's what I
grabbed. It's been really nice. But
honestly, you can probably run this in a
cloud machine without too many issues. I
would be careful using your O with
things like codeex and more importantly
cloud code in a cloud box because
Anthropic does not want you running your
personal cloud code sub anywhere but
your personal hardware. So running it on
your actual local network on your normal
internet less likely to cause a ban. So
personally, I'm not using any cloud
boxes anymore. I did for a bit, but it
isn't actually that hard to roll your
own cloud. And you get significantly
better utilization, significantly better
performance, and way more control if you
just get an old laptop or desktop or buy
some small nuck throw on your network.
You can do a lot. I never thought I
would be the guy writing all their code
in Linux, but here we are. Especially
with my synchronized T-M setup where all
of them are colorcoded for the different
machine and I have clicking on these
working to switch between the different
things going on. any one of the boxes.
And when I have a new machine I want to
set up, I just tell my agent to do it
and it does it. It's so good. I have
never been this happy with my
development experience. There's a lot to
wrangle. Like I've never had to think so
much about what computer should run this
workload, how do I get it to this
machine later? But that orchestration is
actually kind of fun. And I think
orchestration is more and more our job
as we're creating these agents and
environments to work on the actual code
for the products we're building.
Controlling where and how they all run
is more and more our job. And this has
been an incredibly fun way to do it. And
I hope I've inspired you to possibly go
do it yourself. So, if you're tired of
your laptop's fans spinning up for no
good reason, and you want your
performance to look like this while
you're running a bunch of sub aents, I
can't recommend this workflow highly
enough. I am so much happier. I've been
building way more. I've been taking
significantly more advantage of the
capabilities of these AI systems and
agents, and I've finally been getting
close to hitting my usage limits on both
my codecs and cloud subs, and I credit
the setup for it. And one last small
thing for those of us who have set up
Linux in the past and are annoyed by it
or have decided that they don't think
it's worth the effort. It's not that
much effort when you tell Codeex to do
it. It's insane how it's fun Linux is
when you can open up a terminal, open up
Claude Code or Codeex and tell it to
configure the machine the way that you
want it configured. I have had a number
of people ask about using things like
the Codeex cloud product or the Claude
Code cloud product. You guys know, you
guys know I'm a SIM for Codeex. The
cloud stuff just doesn't [\h__\h] work
good. It's just not really there at all.
It's too hard to set up your
environment. It's missing way too many
different things to get that in a way
that's actually viable. Accessing the
code that it wrote to test things out or
try things isn't great. You can't ask it
to use the other model. Like I'll often
tell Codex, go run claude-p to see what
the results are from that to compare and
contrast. Can't do any of that. You get
way less control. you're super locked
in. It's way worse and more broken. So
much so that they've been hiding it. It
used to be very accessible in the mobile
app. I know that because my CTO Mark
used to use it all the time. They made
it harder to get to in the app because
they're even pushing you to use the
built-in remote stuff that exists in
Codeex and now also in Cloud Code with
the remote control option. It turns out
it's really hard to build a generic host
for any agent in any workflow for any
project anyone is building. Cursor and
Devon got a hell of a lot closer because
they're much more focused on this.
Codeex is nowhere near it. I I tried
using these cloud things before and
couldn't really make the jump,
especially with Devon and Cursor as
generous and awesome as they are not
having the subsidized tokens hurt. This
workflow has been much more pleasant for
me and it's actually really fun to own
and control. And coming very, very soon,
the T3 Code mobile app that lets you
control your computers and your agents
fully remotely. It is hard to put into
words just how excited I am to get this
out. And hypothetically speaking, the
whole project's open source. And if you
did want to go build it and run it on
your phone yourself, you probably could.
Just saying. didn't want to make this
video too big a self plug because I
think the Linux box part is much more
valuable and a lot of how we're building
T3 code is based around how much we're
loving this workflow now and in the end
we all have the same enemy which is
holding your laptop open when things are
running and don't you dare tell me
amphetamine is the solution you should
know why that is wrong I got nothing
else on this one I've been loving Linux
I never thought I would be a dev working
in this type of fashion but it is really
really nice I highly recommend you give
it a shot yourself. I bet you'll be
surprised. Let me know what you guys
think.